des codes qr disposés sur les tables des
clients au bout de leur téléphone
cellulaire
dans ce restaurant réputé pour ses
soupes romaine on vient d'implanter un
nouveau système pour la prise de
commande donc pas besoin d'attendre
qu'un serveur vient te voir avec ton
téléphone scanne le code la commune est
envoyé pour commander il suffit de
balayer le code qr avec un téléphone
intelligent j'ai tous les items du menu
aussi bien les cités on choisit son
repas puis on paye l'addition du même
coup on a deux papiers qui vont sortir
la commande et le reçu de vente
saint-prime immédiatement occupions sud
puisque j'ai à faire c'est envoyer la
commande à la cuisine kayak et carragher
et kate moss ça nous sommes énormément
de temps ce qui nous permet ensuite de
mieux s'occuper du client quand on est
dans une grosse période d'achalandage
qui ont peu besoin d'attendre cinq dix
ou quinze minutes pour passer une
commande
le système a été développé par
l'entreprise américaine sound et qui a
réussi à amasser 100 millions $ lors
d'une ronde de financement l'automne
dernier elle a fait l'acquisition de la
montréalaise tchèque please qui offrait
des services similaires afin de
s'implanter au canada et avec le public
d'un leader qu'on voit ici autour de 40
heures en fait assez vraiment une
solution aux à fait efficace qui aime
beaucoup de différents types de
l'histoire
sondhi réclamons restaurateurs des frais
de 2 me à 3 % sur chaque transaction
mais le jeu en vaut la chandelle selon
le gérant de ce restaurant thaïlandais
qui a adopté le système en septembre
dernier on est un restaurant avec
beaucoup de trafic beaucoup
d'achalandage on a beaucoup de commandes
en ligne on a beaucoup de commandes sur
place et donc c'est vraiment libérer du
temps pour que les serveurs et plus de
temps pour pour s'occuper du service
correctement mais la prise de commande
d'un personne ne disparaîtra pas demain
matin
mais bon encore opté le pr bon vieux
menu papier
comme ici on estime qu'un client sur
trois commandes avec son téléphone
intelligent y aura toujours des gens qui
vont vouloir commandant personnes on va
toujours leur offrir les deux
possibilités mais c'est certain que ça
va être de plus en plus adoptée ici
olivier bâche un réseau canada montréal